We have seen some aspects of VLIW.
Now let's discuss VLI backward compatibility as a
quiz. Let's say we have a simple VLIW processor. It has a 64-bit that specifies
two operations, so it's roughly equivalent to
two normal instructions, and let's say that this
processor fetches, decodes and executes, etc, one of
the 64-bit instructions per cycle. Now, we want
to build a better version of this
processor. It can do four operations per cycle.
So, it will need to fetch the code and execute two of those 64-bit instructions
per cycle. The question for you is, is this new processor a VLIW processor? The
possible answers for you are yes it is, or no it's not really a VLIW processor.